Narrator: Americans love beer.
On average, 42% of them prefer it
to any other kind of alcohol,
so you might not be shocked to hear
that according to multiple studies,
over half of American
adults have a beer gut.
But don't swear off your
Friday-night cold one just yet
because it's not beer
specifically that's to blame.
Apple or hourglass, oval
or inverted triangle,
everyone has their own body shape,
and that's partially
because people store fat
in different places
depending on their genetics and hormones.
For women, popular spots
include the thighs,
arms, and backside,
while men tend to store
fat in their bellies.
Much of it is a type of
fat called visceral fat,
which lurks deep within the stomach.
In men, visceral fat tends to pile up
behind the abdominal wall where
it pushes the abs outward,
creating a protruding beer belly.
Though that name, "beer belly,"
is kind of a misnomer
because beer bellies aren't
exclusive to beer drinkers.
That's because the problem
isn't the actual beer.
It's the calories inside it.
On average, your favorite ale
contains around 150 calories per can.
That's 30 to 50 more calories
than a 5-ounce glass of wine
and 45 more than a shot of whiskey.
And if you don't burn them off,
those extra calories can
go straight to your gut.
But not only do the
number of calories matter,
but the kind of calories.
Beer contains high levels
of processed carbs,
which research shows can
interfere with insulin levels
and promote fat storage
around your organs.
And while a serving of wine, for instance,
contains just 1 or 2 grams of carbs,
a serving of beer contains 10 to 20.
It doesn't really matter
whether these calories and carbs
come from beer specifically
or from some other kind of junk food.
So the good news is
beer in moderation shouldn't
give you a beer belly.
That being said, no matter
where it comes from,
a beer belly is bad news.
That's because visceral fat
wraps around your kidneys,
liver, and intestines
and releases hormones
that can disrupt their normal function,
and that can lead to issues
like Type 2 diabetes,
heart disease, and even cancer.
If that's not bad enough,
once your belly runs out of
room to store that visceral fat,
your body might start building
it up inside nearby organs,
which can lead to fatty liver
disease and other issues.
In fact, one study found
that men with beer bellies
or a waste-to-hip ratio over 0.9
had a 87% higher risk for death
than those who carried
the same amount of fat
in other parts of their body.
87%, that's right.
So even if you're otherwise skinny,
a spare tire can threaten your life.
And guys are more likely to grow a gut
as they get older because testosterone,
a sex hormone that helps keep
men slim, decreases with age.
While it's fun to joke about
your developing dad bod,
maybe just stick to having
one or two brewskis a night
instead of the whole six-pack.